[Music]
like the folks you meet on
the brooklyn bridge has been an
indelible part of the new york city
skyline for nearly 140 years when it was
completed in 1883 it was hailed as an
engineering marvel and called the eighth
wonder of the world it also linked what
were then two of america's largest
cities new york and brooklyn the story
of its construction is a drama in itself
and now a new book building the brooklyn
bridge gives readers an inside view of
the 14-year construction process that's
been largely out of sight until now
on a may night in 1983 more than a
million people gathered along the east
river in new york city to say happy
100th birthday to the brooklyn bridge
the celebration included parades
[Music]
street fairs
[Music]
and one of the biggest fireworks
displays the city had ever seen soon
after the bridge opened in the crowd
that day was historian jeff richmond
the mega party touched off a passion in
him for the bridge that's lasted for
decades i was on top of the
eagle warehouse over here
and
it was spectacular and so i collected
an original invitation to the opening of
the bridge
and wood cuts
prints drawings
that collection is the foundation of his
new book
it uses more than 250 images including
stereo views a 19th century version of
3d that gives readers a
never-before-seen view of the bridge so
cool
i'm just in the picture
they tell the harrowing and ultimately
triumphant tale of how hundreds of
engineers and craftsmen worked under
water and high above the river to
complete a construction marvel isn't it
a miracle it is very much a miracle and
it is a
meeting of the most primitive
ideas in terms of technology the bridge
was very much cutting edge in so many of
its aspects the story is rich with human
drama john robling who was well known
for building suspension bridges in other
parts of the country died following an
accident while surveying the site before
work even started his 32 year old son
washington roebling took over the job
but was himself physically unable to
supervise the work and did a tremendous
job but became so exhausted and also
suffered from the bends
as a result of going down into the
caissons that were going to become the
foundations for the towers
that he could not see at times and he
had a telescope where he could watch the
construction the job of conveying
roebling's ideas to the workers was left
to his wife emily who certainly you know
didn't have an opportunity to study as
an engineer but became this key liaison
with contractors with the assistant
engineers to be able to go out there and
even reach the point where she was
consulting
contractors for contacting her and her
alone and asking about specifications
and the demands of the contracts sounds
like she was quite the businesswoman
she was
some might call her the spirit the
father the son
the spirit
the brooklyn bridge completed in 1883
but the work has never really finished
on or around the bridge in the nearly
140 years since it opened
horses and carriages have been replaced
by an early cable car followed by a
thoroughfare that carries more than a
hundred fifteen thousand cars a day and
even a new bike lane to serve the three
thousand cyclists who cross the river on
a daily basis oh my god this looks so
different yes
those changes also include 85 acres of
the former industrial space that's been
transformed over the last decade into
the brooklyn bridge park
eric landau is president of the brooklyn
bridge park corporation where does the
bridge fit into this this landscape of a
story so obviously we are named our park
is named after the brooklyn bridge
brooklyn bridge park it is
such an iconic piece of new york city
and beyond and we right now are in the
last phase of park construction which is
a two-acre area that directly connects
the dumbo section of the park here to
the southern piers in a fitting tribute
that last section of the park set to be
unveiled next month will be named for
the woman so instrumental to the
bridge's construction emily roebling the
idea did not originate with us to name
it after emily warren roblin that
actually came from the community right
but we thought it was such an amazing
opportunity
the bridge has seen new york grow up
kind of get beat down it's seen
renaissance i mean this bridge really
has marked
much of the city's history oh absolutely
and so when the bridge went up those
towers
that you see behind me were pretty much
the tallest thing
in new york and they towered
above
the skyline such as it was in new york
city towered and endured just as it was
predicted by washington roebling who
said there's no reason why the brooklyn
bridge should not remain intact for
centuries what's it like to be
on the bridge
each time you walk these planks
it really is a thrill every time i'm up
here and the energy that you get up here
as you shout above the traffic going by
and the bicycles going by and the
pedestrians going by and this is one of
humankind's great creations
and to be able to enjoy it and stand
under the towers and under the cables
and the suspenders and it's just
wonderful yeah it is
amazing if you haven't been on the
brooklyn bridge if you haven't taken a
trip down to brooklyn bridge park you
have got to make it there because
so much has been improved so much has
been built it is just gorgeous the first
two years i lived in the city i never
walked the bridge i don't know why i
didn't and the next time around i was
much smarter and have done it numerous
times the walk is the best but they do
the new bike lane now bike traffic has
doubled since they opened it seems to be
a big big hit